déclaration d'amour aux forces de
l'ordre des politiques qui promettent de
faire de la sécurité une priorité alors
est ce que ces candidats ce qu'ils
répondent aux besoins de la police c'est
l'heure de notre face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pourrons parler sur ce plateau
pierre vitaly délégué régional des
républicains membres du bureau national
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés en direct par skype josé mendes
secrétaire section ps pays basque
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous également
j'aurais demandé ça on vient d'en parler
à la gauche grande absente de ce grand
oral est ce que ce n'est pas un mauvais
signal que les socialistes envoient ou
aux français pour qui la sécurité fait
tout de même partie des grands enjeux de
la présidentielle
effectivement tous les candidats de
gauche ou en tout cas ceux qui ont été
invités ont compris que les conditions
de dérouler d'un débat serein n'étaient
pas réunies on est effectivement partie
d'un film de grande qualité au demeurant
mais d'une fiction pour parler d'un
sujet tout aussi importante je pense
réellement qu'il aurait été nécessaire
de faire un grand oral sans qu'il y ait
de films et aussi pourquoi pas un grand
oral avec différents syndicats pas
seulement le syndicat alliance plusieurs
syndicats pour un débat est un débat qui
puisse représenter les différents
courants de pensée qui existe dans la
police mais ce qui ne veut pas dire que
nous nous intéressons pas de ces
questions qui sont pour les socialistes
importante et sur ces questions nous
avons bien sûr des propositions et un
bilan tout à fait crédible à défendre
sur ce sujet pierre vitaly justement sur
ce choix de ce syndicat alliance est
vrai qui a finalement été à l'initiative
de cette affiche très diffusés sur les
médias mélenchon 10 ans n'était pas un
congrès en plein meeting d'extrême
droite en gros par même des partis
d'extrême droite at il répondu il a
effectivement préféré tout comme les
candidats de gauche par les logements
qu'est ce que vous répondez savons
vraiment une fracture entre la gauche et
la droite aujourd'hui dans ce qu'elle
est par essence oui écouter sur
surprenant avec la gauche qu'ils aiment
le débat que lorsque c'est avec des
personnes qui sont d'accord avec elle
là pour le coup elle un syndicat y avait
pas que ce syndicat d'ailleurs je pense
qu'il y avait d'autres présentant
d'autres syndicats même si tu es
alliance police qui organisait le film
back nord on n'était pas obligé de
regarder ainsi les candidats de gauche
voulaient pas le voir il n'est pas
obligé de venir on avait juste des
candidats qu'ils n'aient s'exprimer sur
une question qui est extrêmement
importante et si la gauche aujourd'hui
n'est pas capable de répondre à ces
questions liées à la sécurité plus
globalement on comprend pourquoi les
bases ans et son âge c'est une
préoccupation
la droite ne doit pas avoir le monopole
de la sécurité c'est toutes les forces
politiques qui devraient se battre pour
remettre de l'ordre dans nos pays
j'aurais demandé c'est vrai que sur
cette diffusion du film et non il ya eu
plusieurs critiques car notamment chez
vous à gauche on rappelle un petit peu
voilà l'idée du film même si je vais le
résumé certainement de manière un peu
trop lapidaire ici des policiers qui se
sentent
abandonnés finalement par les politiques
par les pouvoirs publics est ce que pour
vous c'est un bon diagnostic ça
correspond aujourd'hui à la réalité dans
notre pays du traitement des policiers
oui tout à fait effectivement c'est un
film que j'ai vu et que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié mais je m'étonne d'entendre
monsieur vital et dire que la gauche
n'est pas capable et n'aime pas le débat
nous avons prouvé nous que nous étions
capables d'aider les policiers je
rappelle que le gouvernement dans le
haut qu'elles participent et madame
pécresse entre 2007 et 2012 a supprimé
près de 13000 postes de fonctionnaires
de police et de gendarmerie
donc ça c'est le bilan de la droite
c'est le bilan de madame pécresse qui
aujourd'hui nous dit qu'elle veut
ressortir le kärcher et de reprendre les
méthodes de nicolas sarkozy mais vous
avez bien vu vous avez supprimer
plusieurs milliers de postes de
fonctionnaires baissé les dépenses
d'investissement notamment pour leur
permettre d'avoir des équipements
correct donc vous avez une lourde
responsabilité la droite dans cette
situation vous devriez d'ailleurs vous
excusez nous aujourd'hui nous avons des
propositions et un bilan crédible je
rappelle que sous la présidence de
françois hollande nous avons essayé de
rattraper le retard le lourd bilan le
lourd boulet de la droite puisque nous
avons recruté près de 9000 postes de
fonctionnaires de policiers et de
gendarmes donc nous avons un bilan qui a
fait positif et nous n'avons aucune
leçon à recevoir de la droite je tenais
à dire ce soir
le diagnostic il est posé les policiers
et les gendarmes sont dans des
situations difficiles
faut les écouter les accompagner c'est
pour ça que nous proposons d'augmenter
aussi le nombre de postes de
fonctionnaires comme nous l'avons déjà
fait les aussi d'augmenter parce qu'elle
baisse ces dernières années les dépenses
d'équipement parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus possible nous le comprenons
d'exercer dans des conditions qui sont
difficiles qu'est ce que vous répondez
tout d'abord à cette critique qui
revient souvent quand on
revient souvent mais c'était il ya plus
de dix ans que la droite était aux
responsabilités moi j'étais en cinquième
donc je veux bien qu'on nous reproche
beaucoup de choses mais je sais
en revanche à quelque chose de plus
intéressant c'est à dire que la droite
est aux responsabilités comme je dis ya
plus de dix ans aujourd'hui elle est aux
responsabilités dans les régions et par
exemple valérie pécresse est là un bilan
qui est beaucoup plus proche est celui
dans sa région ile de france où elle a
fait un bouclier sécurité dans lequel
par exemple à donner la gratuité des
transports pour les policiers afin
qu'ils puissent performer leur travail
et ça par exemple la gauche ne le fait
ne l'a pas fait à rennes à la maire de
rennes qui est dans votre formation
politique l'a refusée on sait
aujourd'hui que la gauche par exemple à
nantes manifeste avec ceux qui crient à
mort la police à mort l'état dans les
bourgeois donc le bilan actuel en tout
cas pas celui qu'on nous rappelle et
qu'on aura d'autres depuis des années le
bilan actuel qui est en train de se
passer il est clair valérie pécresse
elle agit au niveau de sa région et les
les franciliens le vois bien ça c'est
certain d'ailleurs on va voir les
propositions de valérie pécresse ont
finalement le rattraper la droite passé
dit ce qu'elle veut recruter aujourd'hui
7000 policiers et gendarmes ont augmenté
le budget de la sécurité de la police
envoyait l'armée dans les quartiers
difficiles ça on va en parler après mais
tout d'abord justement sur ses effectifs
huit mille policiers a recruté
dernièrement augmentation de la masse
salariale de 21 % en dix ans finalement
josé mendes cette augmentation des
effectifs elle n'a pas conduit
nécessairement à plus d'efficacité est
ce que c'est bien là le problème est ce
que c'est la bonne solution finalement
d'augmenter est-ce qu'il faut pas une
réforme de fond plus tôt alors il ya
deux éléments il ya effectivement le
l'augmentation du nombre de
fonctionnaires qui me semble aujourd'hui
essentielle nous ne proposons pas des
chiffres qui seraient sortis du chapeau
qui seraient des chiffres qui ne
s'appliquerait pas sur une réalité nous
vous proposons une fois élu de créer un
diagnostic local de sécurité et en
fonction des territoires est bien de
proposer un nombre
d'augmentation du nombre de
fonctionnaires mais il faut que ça
marche sur deux pieds le deuxième pied à
mon sens je disais tout à l'heure c'est
l'augmentation des dépenses pour les
équipements je disais que aujourd'hui
lorsque l'on recrute 3 fonctionnaires et
bien on supprime une voiture de police
parce que les dépenses d'équipement
diminué depuis de nombreuses années même
si lorsque nous étions responsabilités
nous avons augmenté donc il faut
aujourd'hui que les policiers et les
équipements nécessaires pour pouvoir
agir au quotidien au service des
français et l'autre point qui me semble
essentiel c'est la formation la
formation des policiers elle est
essentielle aujourd'hui elle passe à 12
mois je pense que c'est une bonne chose
il faut former les policiers pour qu'ils
puissent être tout à fait fort mais être
bien physiquement être bien
techniquement mais aussi juridiquement
pour leur action et je pense qu'il faut
poursuivre ce travail c'est ce que nous
proposons d'investir aussi dans la
formation des policiers pour qu'ils
aient une formation de qualité alors
bien vite elle il ya également cette
proposition de votre candidate envoyé
l'armée dans les quartiers difficiles
vous aller chasser sur le terrain de la
droite dure non va pas chasser sur le
terrain la droite dure on essaie de
répondre à une problématique qui est
réel et il faut arrêter je pense avec le
fait de dire que dès qu'on propose des
mesures pour rétablir l'ordre on nous
accuse de l'extrême droite à force de
dire ça on a aujourd'hui si on à droite
des partis qui lie kia qui arrive à des
scores dans les sondages aidant les
yankees sont énormes il faut répondre à
ses attentes on parle pas d'envoyer
l'armée pour pour régler non plus tous
les problèmes on explique
jusqu'aujourd'hui il ya déjà l'armée
dans avec l'opération sentinelle extra
qui sont dans les villes et il faut
savoir les utiliser pour venir suppléer
t la police aidée la police je suis
d'accord sur l'idée d'investir dans
l'équipement valérie pécresse propose 5
milliards d'euros pour investir
l'équipement l'automobile mais aussi
dans des nouvelles techniques numériques
dans des nouvelles techniques dans plein
d'outils qui sont extrêmement importants
aujourd'hui
voilà valérie pécresse aujourd'hui un
programme solide et capable de rétablir
l'ordre mais pas que sur les questions
sécuritaires de police justement un
projet présidentiel c'est un projet qui
est globale on parle aussi de redonner
la puissance à la justice on parle aussi
de réduire l'immigration on parle aussi
de d'apaiser la société de redonner des
moyens à l'école c'est vrai que c'est
redonner les moyens de la famille est
revenue partout un an dans toutes les
bouches des candidats aujourd'hui il ya
eu ce lien entre délinquance et
immigration ça vous l'assumez on laisse
les enfants dont la toujours assumé à
droite je suis pas sûr que la gauche il
assume aujourd'hui mais en tout cas nous
on l'assumé on essaie d'y apporter des
réponses on assainit valérie pécresse un
peu plus aux rondeurs sur ce type de
sujet à une époque tout de même jeunes
ont enfin elle a quitté le parti pour
recoller ligne droitière que voulait lui
imposer laurent wauquiez par exemple ce
n'est pas que sur la ligne droitière
aujourd'hui fin il faut il faut regarder
les programmes faut regarder l'action et
pas sur les la communication les petites
phrases qu'on peut qu'on peut penser
aujourd'hui c'est patrick stefanini qui
l'a aidé à faire son programme sur la
sécurité on a aujourd'hui des talents à
droite qui l'aideront à appliquer un
programme de droite assumé il faut pas
avoir peur là dessus un nom on a un
parti de responsabilité avec des
personnes sérieuses qui sont cas qui
seront capables de faire concrètement je
pense à quelqu'un comme comme monsieur
péchenard comme monsieur ciotti comme
sur retailleau on a des talents qui sont
là et qui seront là pour appliquer et
pas voilà ces polémiques dans lequel on
essaie de nous de nous de nous placer
quoi je réglais ça vous inspire quoi
qu'on vous entendez ça monsieur
péchenard un proche d'ailleurs de de
nicolas sarkozy qui travaille
aujourd'hui au côté de valérie pécresse
il ne faut pas avoir la main qui tremble
en matière de sécurité c'est une vraie
demande de la part des français à
laquelle la gauche doit également
répondre
doit répondre elle a déjà prouvé je ne
vais pas me répéter mais lorsque nous
avons été aux responsabilités notamment
bernard cazeneuve à être ingrat ministre
de l'intérieur mais je vous confirme que
nous ne chassons pas nous sur les terres
de l'extrême droite de monsieur de
monsieur zemmour de madame le pen ce qui
est le cas je le regrette des
républicains notamment au travers de
monsieur ciotti il faut être ferme sur
ces questions régalienne de police et je
partage aussi ce qui a été dit même si
les désaccords sont nombreux il faut
tenir un discours ferme mais la police
ne va pas sans la justice j'ai entendu
ce matin une mise en cause de la justice
qui est intolérable
la justice et la police doivent
travailler main dans la main pour être
au service des français et aussi nous
proposons d'augmenter sensiblement le
budget de la justice pour que et elle a
lancé un appel le 3 buts magistrats
greffiers il faut entendre cet appel au
service des français encore une fois
en tout cas marine le pen elle aussi
évidemment a pris la parole à on va voir
à l'antenne d'ailleurs s'afficher au cas
légers de nous on faisait un résumé tout
à l'heure les propositions phares de
marine le pen qui mise aussi sur le
recrutement des policiers augmenter
leurs salaires alors c'est vrai que
marine le pen elle concentrerait 60% des
votes des policiers en tout cas c'est
une étude c'est ce qui ressort d'une
enquête électorale du cevipof c'est vrai
que cette enquête elle date de mai 2021
ça veut dire qu'il n'y avait pas encore
eric zemmour y avait pas votre candidate
valérie pécresse aujourd'hui vous pensez
que vous pourrez rattraper cette
tendance se tournant des policiers qui
se sont rapprochés du rassemblement
national je suis certain évidemment il
ya une colère dans la police qui montent
parce que dessous gouvernement macron
sous le gouvernement même de monsieur
hollande j'ai l'impression que c'était
la belle époque mais je pense que les
français savent que nous on n'avait pas
un soutien à la police ils savent que la
droite française les soutient et plus
que les soutenir la droite française est
capable d'agir pour eux et voilà il ya
le problème de la police on propose des
moyens pas que des moyens d'ailleurs il
faut aussi réorganisation une
réorganisation en interne arrêtez avec
une forme d'administration de masse d'or
c'est pas que sur les questions de
police et après pécresse propose un
comité de la hache pour justement des
normes et toute cette paperasse et de
bureaucratie qui nous étouffe et qui
finalement concentrent des
fonctionnaires à des postes
administratifs de bureaux au lieu d'être
sur le terrain et donc donc ya pas non
plus qu'une question de moyens et en
plus les je suis certain que les
policiers seront à nos côtés parce que
la droite française a toujours été à
leurs côtés voilà je vais pas souvenir
que la gauche est toujours été là dans
des manifs ou où souvent on mélange un
petit peu tout violences policières etc
nous on sait que la police est là pour
rétablir l'ordre elle a pas un métier
facile un jeu
je pense qu'on est tous conscients
aujourd'hui que cette place d'aller
parfois dans des quartiers sensibles on
est on est pas bien accueillis de faire
un travail et où la justice parfois
casse ce travail mais c'est pas quelque
chose qui est facile je peux comprendre
une colère de la part des policiers mais
à cette colère doit maintenant s'appuyer
sur comment concrétiser l'action
politique et pour concrétiser l'action
politique fois partie gouvernement faut
un parti sérieux et il ya que valérie
pécresse qui propose jouer mendes bien
vite elle y vient de prononcer de votre
violence policière c'est vrai que c'est
une notion qui est qu on a souvent
entendu un notamment sur le quinquennat
macron avec cet épisode d'aidé gilet
jaune s'est entraîné une forme de
désamour d'une partie en tout cas de la
population et de la classe politique
envers les policiers comment vous vous
situez justement la gauche il faut
rappeler que les policiers et gendarmes
formés métier extrêmement difficile mais
les exercent avant tout avant toute
chose une mission de service public
cette mission de service public elle
doit se faire dans le respect du droit
et de la déontologie qui s'applique aux
policiers il ne faut avoir aucun
atermoiements lorsque certains et c'est
une minorité ont des comportements qui
dévie il faut le souligner les
sanctionner moi je n'ai pas de problème
avec le terme la langue française il y à
des violences qui sont commises par une
minorité de policiers je n'ai aucun
problème à avoir à les qualifier de
violences policières nous proposons
d'ailleurs de créer une autorité
administrative indépendante qui aura
pour charge
examiné non pas dans une phase
judiciariser mais une phrase phase
préalable toutes ces questions de
comportement qui ne serait pas conforme
au droit elle a d anthologie en tout cas
je nous dit nous avons soutien réel des
forces de police contrairement à ce que
ce monsieur a dit monsieur vitaly où les
avons soutenus lorsque nous étions aux
responsabilités nous les soutenons dans
le cadre de notre programme et entre lui
entre la droite et la gauche je dirais
que c'est pas nous qui avons je le
répète mais c'est quand même important
parce que pour savoir où l'on va il faut
savoir d'où l'on vient et lorsque l'on a
supprimé
13 îles postes de fonctionnaires eh bien
ça il faut pas que les policiers l'oubli
c'est le gouvernement de monsieur fillon
avec nicolas sarkozy valérie pécresse
donc ça il ne faut pas l'oublier on va
consacrer à la toute dernière partie
puisqu'il reste plus beaucoup de temps à
auby landes emmanuel macron 1 puisque
mais ne mettront toujours pas candidat
évidemment on le sait être représentée
par son ministre de l'intérieur dont le
propos a finalement consisté à la
défense du bilan du chef de l'état
justement je vous propose de regarder
ces chiffres quelques-uns bilan
sécuritaire sur cinq ans les homicides +
12 % coups et blessures + 31% alors on
va être totalement honnête et dire que
les cambriolages ont également baissé
baisse également de 31 % des vols
violents sans arme c'est un bilan en
demi-teinte pierre vitaly pan vous vous
vous dites que les les cambriolages ont
baissé en perte de confinement encore
heureux je pense que les couvrir la gbc
donc voilà il n'ya pas le bilan et reste
très mauvais et les mauvais et en même
temps c'est normal parce qu'on veut pas
faire justement du en même temps sur les
questions sécuritaires on peut pas avoir
un ministre de l'intérieur qui dit à
élise de la justice qui dit ben voilà il
faut une cohérence politique cette
cohérence politique la droite la porte
tous les jours il ya 765 agression tous
les jours il ya 100 personnes
dépositaires de l'ordre public qui sont
contestés qui sont menacés et donc
finalement le programme de la droite
aujourd'hui c'est de ramener de l'ordre
mais de l'ordre à tous niveaux de
l'ordre de la justice dans la police
comme je les dis mais c'est finalement
ramené une forme de deux mentalités un
respect oui on doit le respect aux
policiers oui on doit le respect aux
pompiers parce que les pompiers sont
agressés oui on doit le respect aux
professeurs et tout ça c'est le rêve
d'une société qui est sereine voilà je
suis pas quelqu'un qui est sécuritaire
absolument je veux juste une société qui
soit apaisée qui soit sereine je juge
que ma génération on n'aie pas peur de
rentrer chez nous tard le soir je veux
juste que les films ma génération et
puisse aller en boîte sans réfléchir à
comment elles vont rentrer etc c2c des
problèmes qui touchent notre génération
et aujourd'hui voilà je suis désolé mais
non la gauche ne soutient pas la police
lorsqu'olivier fort s'est déplacé à la
manifestation de soutien à la police ça
fait du remue au sein du parti
socialiste au sein de la gauche parce
que on aurait peur d'être justement
qualifié d'extrême droite ou de je ne
sais quoi non soutient la police n'est
pas être externe droite c'est juste un
bon sens et je pense que si aujourd'hui
la gauche c est à des scores si faible
c'est justement parce qu'elle refuse de
voir la réalité la réalité du monde
n'est pas forcément
les joyeuses et une partie de
l'électorat qui voter à gauche
aujourd'hui sont sans doute déçus que la
gauche ne prennent pas en considération
ces questions de sécurité et bien qu'ils
soient rassurés la droite n en a pris
conscience j'aurais mendes le mot de la
fin est la réponse rapidement s'il vous
plaît la réponse rapide c'est que je
remercie monsieur vitaly de faire
l'exégèse de la pensée socialiste
n'était absolument pas le cas nous avons
dans notre programme un programme qui
éclaire une république qui assurent
qu'ils assument la justice l'état de
droit et la sécurité pour les français
c'est d'un programme dan dargaud et nous
avons aucune espèce e d'atermoiements
sur cette question je vous remercie tous
les deux joué mendes pierre vitaly
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce décryptage